[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday january 6th
i'm cindy yu the spectator's broadcast
editor
on the show
do vaccine passports work or should we
rip them up kate andrew says the
experiment needs to end and will be on
the show with kirsty innes from the tony
blair institute
england seems to have dodged lockdown
but our boris johnson's fraught
relations with his party and cabinet any
better as a cost of living crisis looms
i'll be speaking to israel hardman
nirola ellemer writes in this week's
magazine about life as a uyghur in china
she has now left but tells me about the
imprisonment of her cousin and how her
parents are under house arrest yet the
state frequently wheels out her mother
in propaganda videos showing how good
life is in xinjiang she'll be on the
show
in a column this week lionel shriver
says we have an unhealthy dependency on
imagining impending doom do we worry too
much i'll be speaking to lionel
and finally at broadway production in
new york last week the actor hugh
jackman praised the understudies and
covers who sometimes learn as many as 10
parts in a play in case an actor can't
make a show
who are these unsung heroes of theater
jenna innes from les mis and rachel
rawlinson from six will join us
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv do you remember to
subscribe to our youtube channel click
the red subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the bell icon to
make sure you never miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine 2.
you can get 12 weeks of the magazine in
print and online along with a 20 pound
amazon belgium for just 12 pounds just
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash tv offer to take it up
yesterday boris johnson announced that
plan b covered measures that stay at
home guidance mask on public transport
and vaccine passports will remain for
another three weeks
in this week's cover piece kate andrew
says the past scheme needs to be stopped
kate joins me now to explain her
argument and to make the case for
vaccine passports curse the innus
director of digital government unit at
the tony blair institute for global
change is also on the show
so kate you went home just after
christmas to see your family in america
but it wasn't without difficulty can you
tell us what happened
so as i was headed to the airport i went
to download my travel pass my vaccine
passport uh through a technology that we
were promised would never become a
vaccine passport but that is of course
what it is uh now
and i discovered that my record wasn't
there it said that my covert record
couldn't be found i then clicked on my
domestic vaccine passport and i got a
notice saying that i had had a positive
pcr test which was true i was delayed in
going home because i unfortunately like
many many people out there got coveted
before christmas and because of that my
app was suspended my vaccine passport
was suspended for 10 days from when i
tested positive on the pcr now this was
temporarily very worrying because i
thought my travel plans were busted
again
as it turns out because i'm an american
citizen that's the one country
essentially i could travel to without
evidence of my vaccine status that i've
been going anywhere else i probably
would have been grounded but also the
information was very odd to me and
conflicting because uh in this country
you don't isolate from when you get a
positive pcr test you isolate from when
you first get your symptoms so it didn't
add up with the rules and whilst once i
dug into the fine print of government
guidance it turns out that this is how
the app works i don't think many people
out there know that at the push of a
button or the registration of a pcr test
your vaccine passport can be suspended
and the truth is this technology is far
more powerful than politicians want to
admit and it turns out quite hard to
control i think so far this experiment
of vaccine passports has highlighted a
lot of the negatives and we've seen very
few of the positive
things that the arguments around vaccine
passports say you're going to get out of
the scheme i don't think it's too late
to ditch it and i think at the end of
the month if mps are asked to to vote
again we shouldn't just suspend domestic
vaccine passports we should be
abolishing them for good
now kirsty what kate what happened to
kate seems
like a glitch essentially because she
was on day 12 of her isolation but the
covered past hadn't been updated in
order to reflect that and that meant
that potentially she couldn't leave the
country but
eve just even so even if it's not
intended to have happened this is the
problem with the vaccine passport isn't
there that it gives a government the
power to limit certain actions and a
government that often is not less than
competent
well what happened to kate sounds awful
and certainly shouldn't have happened i
think if the government's going to offer
this service they've got to make sure it
works and absolutely the vaccine
passport should be in line with the
current recommendations and guidance so
yeah that's a a really bad glitch but i
think the good news is with the digital
passport that would have been relatively
easy to fix and update so that the app
does work in line with whatever the
current restrictions are
probably much easier than um a more
analog system where you've got people
administering guidelines themselves and
having to update a whole team of people
who are who are doing this rather than
looking at an app
but having said that i think that one
person's bad experience or one
glitch doesn't undermine the value of
the tool as a whole which we have to
look at as part of the whole
society-wide government-wide response to
what is a global health emergency
the question is if we think we need to
take steps to
limit the spread of covert round society
how are we going to do that in the most
targeted proportional way possible are
we going to have measures that affect
everyone like a blanket lockdown or
blanket ban of some activities or
blanket travel bans as we've seen with
many countries imposing
restrictions on people who can travel
based on where they're coming from or
are we going to use technology to make
that as smart as we can and just
restrict it for people who we know are
at an increased risk of having or
transmitting the disease
kate what would you say to that
so to be clear it wasn't a glitch and
this is how the app works and if you dig
into the guidance it decides to suspend
your vaccine passport from after you
test positive
for that pcr um now again i don't think
mps were aware that this is the way the
technology worked when they voted on it
i don't think any of this is democratic
but it isn't a mistake it isn't one
person's bad experience there will be
countless people over christmas and and
since who will have discovered that
actually
because of a technology that's already
gotten out of the hands of the state
their movements are restricted the way
that they can go about living their
lives is
restricted and there's no appeal process
here there's no number you can call it's
just computer says no and all of a
sudden your rights as an individual are
suspended and i think this is the
inevitable outcome
of something like a vaccine passport you
know i'm i don't think governments are
generally speaking competent enough to
control such a thing but even if they
were we should all be very seriously
concerned that the government would have
a technology that could at the click of
a button suspend the way we're going
about our lives and i think that the
reason we can have this debate in the uk
and you know a really honest and good
debate about it is that thankfully
compared to a lot of other countries out
there we don't have the same kind of
vaccine hesitancy problem we have one of
the best booster uptakes in the world so
far we have an incredible vaccine
rollout program and for those who still
don't want to get vaccinated we need
better education programs to explain why
we need to do this but broadly speaking
this is a country that wants to be
vaccinated and and one of the benefits
of our incredible success is that we
shouldn't need this kind of technology
to try to use essentially a digital
stick to beat those who aren't compliant
into doing what we want because by the
way that doesn't seem to work in the uk
some countries with relatively low
vaccine uptake have seen that
implementing vaccine passports has led
to more people getting the jab but here
in the uk when scotland brought in
vaccine passports their jab rate was
still in line with england that didn't
have it we're not seeing any of the
so-called benefits that people said we
would get out of vaccine passports we're
just seeing the bureaucracy and frankly
we're seeing an erosion of of the rights
and liberties that that we you know
really cannot take for granted in the uk
they're they're so fundamental and
important and i think this is the time
that we need to re-seize them before
this kind of activity and this kind of
technology becomes normalized
now kesley on vaccine hesitancy uh what
do you make of that because chris
whittie the chief medical officer is
privately saying that he's worried about
what vaccine passports do to vaccine
hesitancy what do you guys at the tony
blair institute think about that
potential conflict
yeah i think it's something that you
need to pay really close attention to so
health passes have got two ways they
help to reduce covert one is by reducing
transmission because if if you're sure
that everyone in a particular space has
either had their full vaccination or has
a recent negative test then you can
reduce the amount of transmission within
that
venue and the government's leaked
research that it could be by as much as
40 to 45 percent and the second way is
by providing people within a nudge or an
incentive to get their vaccine um and or
to have that test
obviously the evidence around how it
impacts people in terms of their
willingness to take the vaccine is
really mixed and it's going to be
different for different populations
there'll be some people for whom they
haven't got around to doing it they
don't see the benefit for them they
don't see the point it just hasn't it
just hasn't you know been part of what
they've been doing
for whom um needing to have a vaccine
passport to go clubbing or to do
something will be enough to say okay
i'll go and get it there'll be some for
whom the reasons for not getting
vaccinated are much more complicated and
much more um
sort of deeply felt and to reach those
people you need a much smarter and
broader range of mechanisms nobody's
arguing that you shouldn't be using the
full suite of tools to get to that
population from information campaigns
making it much more easily accessible
you know sharing the evidence and
helping to reach communities who
understandably have a real trust issue
with government and with with health
health services so it's really
complicated but there are at least two
ways in which health passes can help us
tackle covid and i think that um
you know for that reason we shouldn't be
ignoring them can i just come back on
the point about um competence for
governments i find it really depressing
when people say we shouldn't be using
this or that technical tool because the
government isn't competent to do it the
problem with that is not the technology
it's the government being competent they
must be competent they should be
competent to use these kind of things
and otherwise it's uh it sends a very
sad signal about what services we can
expect from the government and how we
can expect them to look after the
population and provide public services
to us as we go forward and technology
evolves even further
well christie one of the points that
kate makes in her piece is that is this
point about disenfranchisement and maybe
educate you should make this point
because kirsten is talking about those
who mistrust government but i guess the
point is that if you have acting
passports those who mistrust government
are then denied services and hospitality
and access to places
so i think this point about
mistrust and government sorry i'll start
that again um i think this point about
distrust in government is a really
important one um because when we think
about people who don't want to get facts
we often think about
very middle class people who are you
know doing it for extremely selfish
reasons and you know frankly those
people do exist but the figures that the
politicians are really really loath to
talk about but we highlight in the
spectator this week um are the ethnicity
gaps in vaccine take-up and the wealth
gap in vaccine take-up and you know it's
something like 11
of the rich haven't had their vaccine
but nearly i think over a quarter of the
poorest in society haven't had their
vaccine and you know there are deep
vetted social reasons for this and i
don't think that the implementation of
vaccine passports again we haven't seen
any evidence in the uk that the
implementation of vaccine passports is
helping those groups often minority
groups often those who are more
vulnerable in society to take up their
jobs we need a much more thoughtful and
a better education campaign around this
i want to pick up on that point about
transmission because i think the omicron
variant has just completely decimated
the argument around transmission in
favor of vaccine passports so with this
new variant the vaccines are still doing
incredible work they're protecting us
against severe illness that is the most
important reason to get your vaccine
it's the best reason to get your vaccine
the boosters are also working miracles
you know the vaccines are still having
great effect but the omicron variant
does seem to quite successfully
get around infection
vaccines are not as protective as they
once were when it comes to omicron
especially there's a lot of evidence
that astrazeneca for example two gaps of
that which would get you a vaccine
passport is not stopping you from
getting this virus or from transmitting
it's hopefully stopping you from going
to hospital but this idea that if you're
double jab with astrazeneca and you're
in a vaccine passport venue now you are
somehow less of a risk to others um
omicron has dented that argument quite a
lot um and i just think that the
benefits that we said we were going to
get from vaccine passports have not
appeared in the uk but we see problems
with the technology we see government
that can't control it and
yes i suppose in in your dream world
governments would be always thoughtful
and capable of controlling these things
but history would suggest that they very
very rarely are and i highly doubt that
any government that's going to come
along in the near future is necessarily
going to change that basically don't
rely on that look at the technology and
think you know we're getting a glimpse
into what government could control and
and and how well they could do it and if
you don't like what you're seeing in
that glimpse and i certainly don't then
this is going to be the time to change
it because mps at the end of the month
may well have another opportunity to
vote and and the benefits that we've
gotten from the vaccine should mean that
this real push for vaccine passports to
prove your health status when you want
to go about your business and live your
life can be tossed out the window
because living with covid um
has has has meant vaccines it's meant
testing it's meant antivirals but it
really hasn't meant vaccine passports
these have been getting in the way
frankly i think of a broader educational
conversation to have with people about
why they need to take up their vaccines
it's politicizing the vaccines and cindy
as you started to hint at
even the chief medical officer chris
witte is very concerned behind closed
doors about what this is doing to our
public debate around vaccines they
should always be seen as an attractive
feature because scare tactics very
rarely work and there could be real
implications for if we politicize
vaccines in this way what that means for
future vaccination campaigns especially
the core vaccines that we need to help
protect children um so you know the
evidence so far does not stack up in
favor of vaccine passports we have that
very rare opportunity where something
isn't embedded in society to actually
say no we reject this we've had the
experiment it's failed and we're going
to go in a different more liberal
direction and and thanks to the vaccines
frankly we can do that
well kirsty what do you say to that that
omicron changes the game firstly but
also secondly that there's some people
who just will never get the vaccine they
just simply don't want you but if you
implement some kind of passport system
then that means that they've essentially
become second-class citizens
i wouldn't agree with that at all i mean
omicron does change the game but the
fact that it's more transmissible means
we need to do all the more to reduce
transmission you won't ever get to an
absolute stage where you can guarantee
that everyone in a venue is free of
covered or that you're reducing
transmission to zero but you can reduce
it and that's what you should do
in terms of the equity point i think the
stats on the um black minority ethnic
community um take up rates are seriously
concerning and you know the um social
demographic take-up rates are a real
worry but the worry is that these people
are vastly increased risk of getting
seriously ill dying going into hospital
or getting long covered not that they'll
have to take a lateral flow test if they
want to go to a club to me that seems
like a very small part of the problem
indeed
i just wanted to mention something in
case piece that i really agreed with
which is it's great that there is a
demographic democratic process in action
here i think
new bits of technology and new tools
like this should always be subject to
trials piloting
broad public consultation i think it's
great that there's a sunset clause and
there is opportunities to have a debate
in parliament about how this is working
but what i don't think is we've had
enough of evidence yet or enough um
enough kind of public discussion about
how it's working to be able to make a
really good long-term decision so i
would never suggest sort of abolishing
them or ruling them out forever but i
think it's right that you can bring them
in and out depending on the level of
risk and the level of um
concern about covid currently in the
community so it might be that we're at
the stage with omicron where we think
well this is endemic the damage to
public health is manageable and we're
just going to live with this and so it's
right to phase out
a whole suite of the measures that we've
had in place masks social distancing um
and health passes it might be that we
get a new variant cropping up at any
time as we could do since um you know we
haven't got covered under control
throughout the world and if that's more
transmissible and or more deadly we
might well want to have a measure that
we can put back into place like a health
pass to say well um we are doing
everything we can to control the spread
of this variant within our community all
right i mean i'm afraid we have to stop
it there but kirsty and kate thank you
so much for joining spectator tv i'm
sure we have lots more to talk about in
future episodes
now to politics after the owen pattinson
fiasco revelations about number 10
parties the imposition of plan b coveted
rules and slumping poll numbers for the
tourist we ended last year with the
prime minister in a tricky position with
his party has his standing improved or
could a new cost of living crisis bring
the prime minister down
to discuss i'm joined by the spectator's
assistant editor isabel hardman
now isabel before christmas boris
johnson's having a pretty tourist time
now that mps have had a couple of weeks
respite from politics and it looks like
omicron is a little bit milder than
maybe people feared is he a better place
with this party
he's certainly hoping he is he's really
been emphasizing in his commons
appearances this week that he's not been
introducing more coveted restrictions
which really would have been a way of
just dialing back up the the tory wars
straight away straight into the new
term and i've spoken to quite a few mps
who have been long-standing allies of
boris johnson but who felt alienated
from him for various reasons over i'd
say the past year and a bit uh who he's
uh been making quite a lot of personal
effort with so he's had them in um for
jake berry told me that he went into
downing street just before christmas for
what he described as a big session and i
think that was them talking about
leveling up rather than really going
heavy on the cheese and wine and but
there have been others who have also had
time with the prime minister one-on-one
where he's clearly been trying to to
show them that they matter and that's
something that's really important to
tory psychology
i've been writing about them for over a
decade now and i have to say that one of
the
easiest ways to alienate your mps is
just to not make them feel loved and
that was something that david cameron
really struggled with it was often a bit
like um teenagers at a disco sort of
upset that someone hadn't looked at them
enough um and so just paying them a
little bit of attention is something
that matters so much more to
conservative mps than it does for
instance in the labour party and so it's
interesting that johnson clearly has
realized that things are serious enough
that he needs to make sure that people
he probably assumes that his friends are
still really on site so there's that
but i don't think that things are going
to be plain sailing
by any means over the next few weeks he
still has
a lot of issues we've got the issue
which i'm sure we'll discuss over um the
national insurance rise which jacob
rees-mogg um has been pushing for we
still have inquiries going on into the
downing street christmas parties
um and boris johnson has been very clear
that he's not going to be someone who is
going to change and so his uh his
enemies those who are quite hoping that
he does go
uh expect that the pattern of behavior
that they've seen over the past few
months is just going to continue and at
some point again mps are going to be
disappointed by boris johnson
well let's talk about that jacob
rees-mogg intervention because so jacob
rees-mogg said that cabinet a campaign
against this national insurance hike
which had already been uh announced and
decided really but boris johnson has
more cost of living crises coming down
the line doesn't he because there's
rising inflation there's also these
energy bills which the government has
said they're refusing to take away the
vat for so all of these things even
without coverage are going to be
arguments within the party
they are and i think if you saw
conservative mps agitated about partying
in downing street before christmas
it'll be on a different scale once a
cost of living crisis really starts to
hit their constituents and they get a
lot of
anxious
communications in there in their email
inbox and letterbag and i think that's
when things could get really serious for
the prime minister because if voters
feel that their lives are getting worse
under the conservatives then of course
they're going to start looking for
alternatives and the next election isn't
you know it's not imminent but it's not
that far away either and so this is
something that boris johnson is going to
want to get a handle on but it again is
something that's very difficult for a
government to get get a handle on it's
very difficult to control global energy
prices for instance it's also very
difficult domestically to control
inflation particularly if you're putting
up taxes and that's why this jacob
rees-mogg intervention at cabinet this
week is quite so potent because
conservative mps
were pretty unhappy with the national
insurance hike to uh as ministers claim
fund social care but really it's largely
going to the nhs and it's very difficult
to see how it will stop going to the nhs
in the next three years when it's
supposed to switch to social care but
now this cost of living crisis is with
us and looming as a much bigger crisis
conservatives are even more
uncomfortable about putting people's
taxes up i think it's worth saying that
jacob rees-morg
has seemed to be on his way out of the
cabinet for a little while not least
because of his role in the owen
patterson saga which really kicked off
boris johnson's autumn and winter of
discontent
and it's been a question of whether he
is going to be pushed or jumped first i
think he was reportedly
very unhappy about covert restrictions
before christmas particularly when lord
frost quit the cabinet um and boris
johnson may be seeking to do a sort of
refresh of his top team and his cabinet
in the next few months so he might be on
his way out he might feel that actually
now is the time to use the firepower he
still has as a cabinet minister to
represent some of the back benchers who
he feels most at home with
that's really interesting as well you
mentioned david frost there as well do
these people who are no longer in
government post a greater threat i mean
now that they're more and more of them
racking up in boris johnson's
premiership and also with david frost
there's a particular brexit angle there
isn't there because one of the reasons
he cited for leaving was that boris
johnson wasn't fully utilizing the
benefits of brexit and people might
point to the energy crisis and say now
that he can abolish the 80 on energy
he's not doing it
and that's one of the reasons that's one
of the
symbols of not using the brexit dividend
absolutely yes that's one of the very
potent effects of frost's resignation is
to highlight
really promises that boris johnson made
and we had this highlighted by harry
cole of the sun at the press conference
this week in downing street where he
pointed out that boris johnson had
written an article in may 2016 about
this vat on
energy bills
and now we have conservative mps saying
well come on boy johnson you know you
yourself said that this was something
that if we left the european union we
could do it it just so happens that you
could actually do it anyway if you were
still in the european union because
policy has changed but you know whatever
the point is is that it's something that
the prime minister can do and isn't
doing and i think he's belatedly arguing
that it would be a crude instrument
something that um that wouldn't actually
help the the poorest uh but i think
something needs to change in the way
that uh ministers and boris johnson
approach this cost of living crisis
rather than just listing what they're
already doing
often you just need to sort of feed the
beast and say actually there is
something we can do so we could take the
green taxes that are on energy bills out
of energy bills and put them into
general taxation for instance which
would uh hit the richest uh much harder
than fiddling around with the energy
bills themselves
and as well finally i can't let you go
without talking about your piece in the
magazine this week which is all about
antivirals tell us about them and why
are they important well it's really
interesting because the vaccine task
force and the vaccination program have
really become i think part of sort of
britain's
cultural identity haven't they you'd see
lots of people on facebook and twitter
with their i've got my covid vaccine a
little sort of avatars and people walk
around wearing their badges which always
reminds me of when i was like five and
i'd just been to the dentist and i had a
sort of gold star badge for brushing my
teeth but it's become sort of part of
our identity in a way that the nhs has
become part of our identity we're you
know we're proud of these things we're
proud of our vaccination program most of
us are proud to have been vaccinated but
the antivirals program is also actually
the the biggest in the world in britain
but it hasn't got the same cultural
cachet as vaccines and what it is for
for those who um well like me until i
started then writing this piece didn't
know very much about it is at the moment
there's 1.3 peop 1.3 million people
in this country who are deemed
clinically vulnerable and
they
can if they get a positive pcr test have
an antiviral pill
delivered to their home or get a friend
to go and collect it from a nearby
delivery unit and if they take this
within the first few days of getting
symptoms or testing positive it
dramatically cuts the risk of them being
hospitalized or even dying one of their
tablets we
this country has bought i think cuts it
by
between 30 and 50 another one of them i
think cuts it by around 80 so
really quite dramatic results and what
it means is obviously people aren't in
hospital uh there's less pressure on the
nhs in a hospital setting there's also
actually it's much easier for for gps to
you know administer one prescription of
a pill than it is to take somebody into
a tertiary setting so it reduces the
pressure across the board on the nhs and
it gives us a glimpse of covert becoming
an illness that we just deal with in the
way that we deal with flu and so i
interviewed the chair of the
government's vaccine task force this
week eddie gray
about the program
sorry i interviewed the chair of the
government's antivirals task force this
week eddie gray about the programme that
he's been running and it's you know it's
still um early days a lot of these drugs
are still we don't know what the sort of
some of the end effects might be i asked
him about the uh the impact
of antivirals potentially on creating
new variants and he said that was
something that they were obviously very
alive to i think a lot of people when we
talk about antibiotics think about
superbugs and that's not quite the right
language in the context of antivirals
but it is something that that scientists
at the sage committee are are very alive
to but it could be
a really important part of of our
program for for getting used to covid as
being part of our life rather than
something that changes and disrupts our
lives as it has over the past two years
well that's incredible and i hope it's
as much a success as the vaccines task
force has been as well thank you so much
for joining spectator tv
nirola element is a china researcher
living in sweden she is also a wigan
whose family are experiencing first-hand
the chinese government's persecution of
the weaker people she writes about what
life was like in xinjiang the
imprisonment of her cousin and her
mother's rather unique role in the
government's efforts in this week's
issue and she joins me on the show now
so nirela you're joining us from sweden
right now where you hold citizenship but
you were born and you sing down in china
can you tell us what was life like in
china as a weekend
i was born in a wool jar in shin in
oldest city in xinjiang weaker
autonomous region
and the life as a weaker in there
usually is most of the job they will
only accept han chinese and for weaker
people
some of sometimes the job application
will just set say
no eager
and then being a wiggler also means you
will face like a daily discrimination
all the time
but we
we arranged final time to like we we
survived
and then we try our best to be the one
of the best module weaker for the
chinese government so we can have a
normal life but then since getting
started to getting worse since 2009
and then um
it's also uh when is the time then i
started thinking maybe i should leave
you mentioned 2009 then in your article
you talk about that year how you were
refused from hotels and even reported to
the police for trying to get rooms in
hotels as you traveled across china that
was also the year of violent clashes
between uyga and the han
han chinese and the local police as well
in xinjiang which ended up with over 100
people dead mostly han so it must be a
very febrile time when you left xinjiang
um
it the protests start with the uyghur
start with a peaceful protest but the
government
strikes back really hard in the
you know so the protest ended up as a
riot but uh the government said most
people died as a han chinese but they
never revealed the how many uyghur died
in the next day and the third day
because chinese people also went down
the street and
to did the retaliation
so yeah it was really
it was a tough time for both chinese
people and for the weird people
and
but since
the government started doing a lot of
propaganda repeatedly showing with your
face weaker violence faced on the news
and on the video and then i start feel
like um
everybody look at us like we're some
kind of potential terrorist and these
kind of things you will feel in the in
the daily life
uh
wherever we go
we have to open our back the
you know like a body like a guard they
will check our back and then if we take
on bus they will do that and when i go
to the mainland when i start work at the
mainland and then
i can clearly feel
i'm not welcome there either
and i guess here some context for
viewers as well which is that the
singdown region is so to the west of the
country
and uighurs mostly live there so for the
majority of the han chinese of which i
am a member you know you live on the
other side of the country you might
never even come across a wigan in your
life you hear about uyghur terrorism or
uighur separatism and then you see one
on the streets and all sorts of
prejudices fly so i think that is the
very real sectarianism that's happening
in china at the moment and neroli when
you say you and your parents made a
decision for you to leave
since then it's got much much worse for
uyghurs in in this intensification
intensifying of the uyga policy where
you've got internment camps you've got
labour labour from these so-called
graduates of the camps and you write
about your cousin maila who has also
fallen foul of the authorities in this
policy can you tell us about what's
happened to her
it was
2018 uh march 2nd
um
okay sorry let's go back to 2017
actually 2017 around november i received
a message from my mother told me she can
no longer to contact with me anymore
and then i also received a message from
my cousin mahila
she also
like sent a
like a goodbye message to me and to her
own sister in australia
so at that time we already heard people
are
getting like a losing contact with their
own family members so i thought okay now
it's our turn but as long as my parents
and my cousin my relatives are safe are
at home
i can accept the chinese government
doesn't allow them to contact with me i
can accept that as long as they're safe
but then in 2018 march 2nd
she disappeared
and it took me
around
7 to 10 days to finally find out what
happened to her
she was taken to the camp
to a internment camp with chinese
government called as re-education camp
but its internment camp
is ex-tradition camp
she was detained there for 10 months
and when she finally released it was
a 2018 christmas eve
at that time i even thought it's um you
know like a miracle finally she's home
and i even thanks to the like
thanks to the chinese government have
the mercy on her she's fine she's home
but then later i found out which she
told me
they starved her
she lost 13 kilo
in that 10 months and then she she was
diagnosed the liver damage
and then i saw well at least she's at
home at least she's at home fine you
know and then
in three months
they took her again
and then they detained her in the
pre-geo detention center for 17 months
and then they released her
only one for one night and then they
took her again and this time they
sentenced her for six years and six
months that's how i lost my cousin
and obviously the chinese government
says all of these this these measures
are for anti-terrorism and
anti-separatism would they accuse your
cousin of
um they accused my cousin for financing
terrorist activities
which
uh
it was she sent money to her parents in
australia to purchase a house in 2013.
and then government calls it as
financing terrorist activities
i
with with uh several journalists help i
sent and they also send the facts the uh
the evidence can prove my my cousin's
innocence
for example like bank transfer
records
and a house contract everything to show
to the chinese government that money is
indeed to purchase a house in australia
but it doesn't matter for the chinese
government
you send money to abroad to purchase a
house in chinese government's eyes
because you're weaker so your your
terrorist or your financing terrorist
activities
and what's particularly striking about
your story your article is the different
space that your mother occupies in this
entire saga can you tell us about what
she is doing
the accused they accused my parents for
um
howling uh extremist items and uh
according to the police of
the prosecutor documents anna according
to the police it was
66
uh
photos pictures they took the
as a you know they took in malaysia when
they were traveling there and a
government set
is uh extremist items and
in relation to the maya's case my
parents has been under house arrest
since 2018
2019
april
and she can yes she can
go out to
buy
grocery
um
but she's not allowed to leave the city
she's not even allowed to call her
sister in urunti in another city
so
yeah but
of course even she was under house
arrest for chinese government she's a
perfect propaganda material they can use
so when they need her they will took her
to you know have this kind of the
propaganda
agenda
so and that's because as you write in
your article she she loves singing she
has won competitions for it and so they
have been using her to propagate this
idea of a happy or singing or dancing
wiga
yes she loves to sing and she wants a
lot of like region
uh region award and because she speaks
perfect mandarin so for them she's a
very
muggy wigger and they always they always
ask her to talk about the importance for
the weaker people appreciate show their
gratitude to the chinese communist party
to xi jinping and
it's important for uyghur to remember
how the party has been doing good for
them so yes she become a propaganda
mouse piece for the chinese communist
party when they needed her
how does she feel about that considering
the the experience that your family has
been going through or are you not able
to i guess talk about this sort of stuff
given that you are in sweden any
communication between you would be
through wechat i guess which is a
monitored social media platform
i
to be honest i never talked about this
with my mother because for her in her
for her what is the most important thing
is she can take care of the maya's three
kids
when the chinese government took to
maida they're not only confiscated her
money they also suspend the maida's
parents pension so they left empty hands
to her three kids
so for my mom the most important thing
is what can i do so i can
stay at home take care of her three kids
because my mom know once they took if if
she's not obey
then the chinese communist party can
took her
can take her chinese communist party can
take her take my my father
and then these three kids will ended up
in orphanage orphanage or uh you know
the state's
uh
sponsored boarding school for weaker key
with your kids
what about you i mean you are in sweden
and you're i mean i hope that you're
relatively safe but obviously speaking
out against the chinese government still
will impact your safety but do you not
concerned when you're talking to media
like us for example you've talked to
lots of american outlets about
your story
do you worry about your parents
especially your mother because they all
know who she is
every time
when i speak up
i'm worried and i'm scared
every time
before i speak up
i will have a lot of thought in my mind
will this take
bring risk to my family will this bring
disaster to my family
but then i also know if i don't speak
out
they will continue to do these kind of
things not only to my parents they will
eventually come to my ears three kids
and then i every time after i speak out
i always have a panic attack
you have to understand
you have to understand the chinese
communist party
is very scary
i
i am afraid i am scared but i have to
speak out
what what what is hap
the crime they did to my family to put
the innocent people in the internment
camp
in prison
if i don't speak up
about that
i don't know what will happen next
nirola element thank you so much for
joining spectator tv
now from nuclear apocalypse to worldwide
famine to now perhaps climate change
lionel shriver ponders in this week's
issue why people including her are so
obsessed with visions of impending
existential doom she joins me on
spectator tv now
now lionel i loved your column this week
which is all about the various ways in
which people throughout history have
feared how armageddon might come tell us
about it
well i wouldn't wasn't looking at uh
from the beginning of time i was
thinking about
the kind of rhetoric i'd been subjected
to and
threats to
the world as we know it
ever since i was a kid
and naturally
since i was born in the late 50s i grew
up under the shadow of nuclear war and
one of the things that i would have in
common with my generation is
having nightmares uh with some frequency
about explosions of mushroom clouds and
you know it was
it was terrifying
and then you know shortly after that was
the
population
uh explosion and
uh
easy to forget now but uh
it was widely predicted
that
we were going to exceed the carrying
capacity of the land and pretty soon we
were all going to starve
i took
the overpopulation thing very seriously
uh
i've been interested in demography as a
consequence
for my whole life
it's been a fascinating field partly
because of
what didn't happen
nobody predicted
the green revolution
which transformed the production of food
uh multiplied the production of food and
nobody
expected that in the west at least uh
population would not over only
level off
but
achieve such a low
fertility rate that it would start to
the population would start to contract
and that that was not foreseen at all
and the column goes on to
elucidate
a
host of other
grave threats to our existence including
of course
in the 1970s it was predicted that the
world was cooling and we were going to
freeze to death
i mean this is all by way of
trying to achieve a little perspective
on the present which is
always difficult to achieve
at the best of times
and i'm just finding
that all this climate change stuff about
about which i have not
positioned myself i'm
i'm something of a neutral party
but i'm a distanced one
so i'm just
i'm a little suspicious this
rhetoric of apocalypse
i've lived with it my whole life
and i'm still here
and so are you
so
i'm taking it with a grain of salt
i think everyone's probably got at least
one of these concerns why do you think
there is such a fascination with you
know catastrophic extinction events
i think it makes
life seem more urgent
more exciting
uh it makes
the decisions we make now
appear to be consequential
uh i think there's a there's a mirroring
in
uh in
the apocalypse of our own mortality
so that
you know the very structure of our lives
is apocalyptic we recognize it
we're facing oblivion
believe it or not and uh
there's a tendency to project
that
small apocalypse onto the world at large
but i think otherwise it just it makes
people feel more important
it puts everything at risk
and in the west
we seem to need that if anything
we've grown more apocalyptic
because our lives are so comfortable
we need to introduce
a
peril
you know put ourselves back on the belt
and
you know out of the lounge chair
do you think it's almost a survival
instinct so not only
this instinct to go with the crowd but
also to foresee potential problems and
then use anxiety to motivate finding
solutions
one of my covers that there are
interested groups who are promoting
particular anxieties and and it suits
their
agenda i mean that's one of the things
that i've been buffeted by my whole life
is various groups who
have an interest in a problem
uh if you want to be cynical you could
say they are profiting from a problem
and therefore they want it to be as bad
as possible i mean i was
interested
in researching my fourth novel game
control which is all about a mad
demographer
uh i i needed to
[Music]
compare
studies uh
what the
population consequences would be in
africa in particular
for the hiv epidemic
and there were
any number of epidemiologists who
thought that the population of africa
was going to plummet
and then there were the studies by the
demographers
and they didn't think hiv was going to
have the slightest bit of difference and
the real problem for the continent was
escalating population growth and to me
that that was a revelation
because
it was
one of the first times i stepped back
and looked at it and saw
who i see i mean these these are these
were sincere groups of people
they genuinely believed their research
though their research was slightly
rigged in favor of their pet problem
uh but
self-interest contaminated their results
and i think you see that
in with a lot of disasters oh i guess
also
disastrous
sorry line i was just going to say oh i
guess also specializing in a particular
field without seeing the wider picture
perhaps
oh we see that with covid right now
you know all the
seons of disease are
um
well they're having their moment this is
great and if something in them doesn't
want it to end regardless of what they
say
yeah and how do we know which of these
are real and which will pass with
nothing happening because i mean some of
them must be real concerns but how do we
tell which one is which
uh in the process that's very difficult
yeah you know i in the column i
acknowledge that
not only are a lot of problems that i
cite real but uh acting on a couple of
them has ended up being
uh
beneficial and and important you know
the fact that we banned
hydrofluorocarbons
uh
has made a significant
difference to
closing holes in the ozone layer
i am glad
that we have brought in more stringent
regulations for emissions in the air and
water
so that by and large
the pollution situation has improved
not everywhere
if you go to delhi or beijing you
wouldn't say the same thing but the west
has
you know in some ways literally cleaned
up its act and that was in response to
alarm
which could have been interpreted
interpreted as alarmism
and one of the
one of the
things that made acting on pollution
easier though is that you could see it
and i would say that on climate we think
we can see it but i don't think so
that is we can see it too up close and
now we're supposed to be looking at
individual extreme weather events and
every single time anything happens
anywhere that's a little out of the
ordinary then it's always climate change
now i'm i'm mistrustful of that
and on climate change you also say that
you're mistrustful on the use of the
word zero whenever that word comes out
it seems is it too absolutist is that
fair to say
yeah i think that uh the the use of the
word zero is
a red flag of absolutism
so the zero covet
movement
uh like the zero population growth
movement of my youth
not to mention the net zero policy
they all sound
uh iffy to me
because
zero is the mark of fanaticism
and lionel finally do you think that the
media is also to blame i'm aware of the
irony of asking you this from the
spectator offices but perhaps too often
yeah well we can't resist the punchy
headline can we
um
clearly clearly the media are widely to
blame on everything i'm
you know we seem to be in a time that uh
that the media
largely speaks with one voice and i
think that's never healthy
unlike the spectator
well that's a lovely note to end on
lionel thank you so much for joining
spectator tv
this is my pleasure
and finally what happens when stars of
western shows come down with covet with
a wave of infections over the last
couple of months understudies have had a
more important role than ever with some
of them stepping in with only minutes
notice i'm joined now by the actresses
jenna innis on the cast of les mis and
rachel rawlinson on the cast of sex
so rachel to start with tell us what you
do in your role as a swing on sex this
western musical about henry viii six
wives
yeah so um the musical is called six and
as it suggests there are only six people
in the show
um and i cover them all so i know the
whole thing well
i say i know the whole thing i have a
lot of maps and charts and
i refer to my score and script before i
go on um so yeah essentially i could go
on for
any of the six wives of henry viii um if
needed so if someone's off sick or if
someone's injured or we actually have a
nine show week um and everyone's
contracted to do eight so if if it is
someone's night off i might go on um so
that's essentially what i do there's a
quite a lot of roles and characters to
remember how do you fit it all in
it is it is but they've been brilliant
at sort of
when we started it wasn't okay here's
the whole show learn it off you go um it
was kind of a case of right we'll start
with one and then we'll progressively
build up so now i've done three um i
have a fourth debut on sunday um so
we're getting there slowly but surely um
but yeah it's a lot um but the team are
brilliant like i say you know everyone's
there to lend a helping hand and there's
other alternates um and obviously the
queens themselves that can help us out
so yeah
and
jenna let me bring you in here because
you've been a cover for eponine in les
miserables but over the weekend you had
to cover for fun team which is not a
role you were covering for is that right
that's yeah that's right yeah so i'm
actually on the uk tour of uh les mis
right now not in the west end production
so they got um just with so many people
isolating and what's happening right now
they had to get a few of us
in
from the tour just to help cover
the
parts and things like that so um i was
there as an understudy for eponine and
then suddenly the
second cover fonting
went went down she she was ill she just
couldn't do it so
the show must go on as they say so we
had to literally just had an hour before
the show just to run through things and
to get it and i've been singing it in
the shower since i was 11. so i was like
should be fine didn't really think it
through it was in the wings i think it's
too late to say no now so and just did
it is that all the is that all the
practice and is that how you learnt the
role through to sing it in the shower
like you would there was no studying
beforehand that the play had the
production
officially because yeah like you say
it's not a rule that i officially cover
so it's not um i haven't had any
rehearsals with mds or haven't sung it
through with anyone it's just one of
those
you know
songs and and bits and bobs that you
kind of known because i've been in the
show for quite a while you know you hear
it a lot and you see a bit of it but
doing it is a completely different beast
um
and it was it was absolutely it was wild
but it was great fun it was amazing
how much notice were you given before
they said given about three hours notice
i got the call about 11 o'clock in the
morning for a 2 30 show
and so and then i went into the theater
at 12
and had an hour's rehearsal
i'm stressed just hearing about this
rachel i guess you'll know you're no
stranger to this sort of last minute
subbing on as well did you have to sub
someone mid show at one point
i did i did i was sitting in the green
room
actually doing some more of my maps and
we noticed that um the alternate didn't
come on for one of the numbers as
seymour and i thought
should i be worried and they're like nah
and then suddenly someone came out hello
ladies and gentlemen uh we're gonna have
to stop the show while we have a quick
cast change so i ran literally got i i
honestly looked awful it was it was a
total transformation
slapped on some makeup did my hair um
had like wigs and wardrobe on me and
and yeah you just have like jenna said
with i dreamed a dream you have this
moment of like i just have to trust that
i know it
i i had no time
because usually to if i know i'm going
on i'll spend my train journey you know
going through the material and
in the morning or whatever
um but you just have to go i guess i
guess i know it i will see what happens
there's no other option is it at that
point it's like you've just got to you
have to so there's no point in panicking
yes yeah go through and typically i'm
sure this goes for all companies
people in the industry understand how
stressful it is to be a swing and an
understudy so for instance that night i
had five of the principal queens on with
me
so i also had that reassurance of
knowing that
if i did go wrong which i will add i
didn't
but if i did
if i did i know that they would help me
you know and i can linger back and find
the space that i need to be in um but i
mean yeah that was i came off and i was
like that was the biggest adrenaline
rush
ever ever so stressful and there was one
moment where um i don't know how
familiar you are with the show catherine
passings a lovely ballad well it's a
ballad that goes into an up-tempo near
the end and we're all sat down and i'm
doing my best acting you know listening
but in my head
i'm fully just visualizing where jane
seymour goes for the rest of the show
i'm here then i'm here then i follow
this queen and i'm here and i sing this
line what line am i on you know so
there's a lot um my eyes weeping
there's a lot there's a lot going on in
the brain but um yeah it's a lot of fun
crazy um and jenna what is it like to be
an understudy because i think viewers
maybe um have this image in their heads
of all about eve where the understudy is
constantly scheming to get the main role
off in some way i mean obviously covert
takes that question out of uh out of the
question anyway but what is it like
jenna to be to be that understudy i
guess it's not as competitive probably
really not it's really really not and
the women i cover are fantastic they are
brilliant they're so supportive and when
ever they've got to go off and i've got
to go on you know they'll um always
message and send love and support and
you know have a great show sort of thing
and i really enjoy it like kind of like
what rachel's saying it's the it's the
the last minute the sort of chaos of it
all i really enjoy i've been throwing on
mid-show as well you know interval to do
the rest of the opening track which is
sing her big song and die which is quite
oh you know it's a bit of a whirlwind
but i quite enjoy that sort of quick
pace or even any day every day is a
little bit different and it can happen
at any point i i really enjoy that um
and i hope i'm not a hunger study i hope
i don't come across as
is that what i called a hunger study go
study yeah you can get there
quite enjoy that i know
i really enjoy it
and rachel do you find that sometimes
how do the audience receive understudies
not necessarily you personally but i
mean obviously there have been horror
stories where the audience literally
boos when the main
actor that they've come to see is not
able to be on stage and obviously that
puts the understudy in quite a difficult
position
yeah absolutely i mean i think
with six um and i did heather's before
they both have
really big fan bases and they're super
supportive and they are so welcoming so
actually when i came on uh mid show was
seymour i got a big cheer which was
lovely um but no i think as well
there has been in the last
maybe 18 months i think more of a
limelight put on under studies saving
the show and i think certainly if you're
not in the industry there can be an
element of oh well we haven't got the
main person today you know we've got
we've got the the backup but actually i
think
a kind of blessing from kovid which i
mean i'm sure there's not many but one
one of the good things for understudies
is you must have seen so and i guess
like this like there's so many more
opportunities for us to recognize that
under studies and swings are literally
saving shows you know people are able to
see a show because
of people like me and jenna because we
you know jenna is like okay i'll do a
track i've never done before sure we'll
see what happens um which which i think
is amazing and i'm so glad that
understudies and swings are you know
finally being recognized for the hard
work that they do um because you mean
you just wouldn't have a show without
them yeah there's this feeling that it's
like a second rate um sort of thing but
it's really not like
you know like you say you shouldn't
notice when an understudy's on and most
of the time you don't because they're so
brilliant
because they'll just fit in perfectly
you know and you don't notice if it's an
understudy you don't know it's a dip in
quality at all
and that's
because you know understudies and swings
they know their job very well that
you know it is a good is now finally
they're being recognized a little bit
when celebrated so much more it's
brilliant
well jenna do you think moving on from
covid then this is the lesson that the
industry can take which is just to give
understudies a bit more breathing space
a bit more opportunities to show what
they're capable of instead of having the
main start on you know eight shows every
nine shows is there a way forward where
you know it's you're a bit more dynamic
about giving people opportunities to
shine yeah well maybe yeah maybe this
could be a little um a thing where they
celebrate or you know they announce it
more they you know celebrate it on
social media more and say you know for
this week if someone's on holiday you
know this week it will be
instead of it not like being a secret
but just kind of like slipping under
they should maybe make announcements and
celebrate the fact because you know
backstage like you'll know rachel
backstage it's very much celebrated and
you know and the the company pooling
together is fantastic and you get so
much support and love from all
departments and so it would be nice for
that to transfer out front so that the
audience can kind of do that too the
audience can show their appreciation and
their support for the understudies too
because i'm sure i'm sure they would
love to if they knew if they knew it was
happening because maybe maybe you don't
know it's an understudy maybe you're not
if you're not in if you're not in the
fan base if you're not on social media
and stuff like that you might not know
yeah absolutely well jenna innis and
rachel rawlinson thank you so much for
joining spectator tv
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
this episode don't forget to subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel just
click the subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the bell icon so
you never miss an episode thanks for
watching and do join us again next week
[Music]
you